okay guys I'm from Glasgow yes
Oh Glasgow steel with collot guns are
illegal yeah so I strap up with that gun
dog can't get a stick it boys dogs in a
harness a little hound on your chest
oh shut up Glasgow it's got it's kinda
like cows same with legs you can wear
Georgia tonight if you have nice legs
you support a nice fresh pup on your
chest if it's the cute pup don't put
them little ugly pugs on your chest and
[ __ ] man or get yeah or you got a Boston
Terrier with this dick or you got a
wiener dog and like half of it hanging
off your thigh but you only see people
doing small dogs I would like to see
somebody with a [ __ ] rocking a Great
Dane you know yeah get that [ __ ] lab
on your chest
chocolate lab dude it could be in a
little huh dog tough man
build up them thighs get some George
yeah throw them shorts on and get you a
little don't get you like a little
Pomeranian no that's what [ __ ] man
yeah get that British Bulldog get that
English Bulldog just hang on each hip
yeah well they don't have do they have
the little dogs like they do in the US
do they have those in Ireland no yeah
Terriers but not use that oh it's
Stratford Shire Terriers yeah but like
yeah it's usually big ones Labradors or
Saint Bernards I don't know what the
[ __ ] they're never my aunt at a dog he's
a chaise Mima brought around a house and
she's like he's only having fun well
he's trying to bite us what kind of dog
was it it was more exotic dog dude every
time I give him the spaniel for I give
him the card goes comes laughs it's why
his cocker spaniel one of the other baby
I'm still afraid of dogs though my
brother like ran into a sliding door
like a glass door boss his face often
the Glasgow smile doctor hair come like
stitch of Arthur yeah so now if I see a
dog back and I just think it's your
brother really it's
all of the dogs a glass door sound like
the iris Olympics keener singing dogs in
harness Kenya but it has to be the right
kind of dog don't be putting a little
[ __ ] dog than your chest man yeah I
wouldn't mind seeing a great day in a
husky at Chow I used to share a room of
the Chow not an Asian guy like is it
really yeah charge house do my god they
are they're violent looks like a little
teddy bears dude strap a cane corso to
your chest yeah goes for you man ya hear
that 200 pound animal ugh yeah do some
work man you let him to switch off like
a woman with big breasts those things
are baby like feel now I empathize their
violent ChaCha's on me yeah hoarsely no
they bite more people than pitbulls no
problem they'll pretend they're sleeping
and when you try to leave the room the
paid oh I think that's one of you
probably know well I rented a room
University Arizona from my guy up there
your roommate was a Joe and I got there
and he said the only problem with this
room you have to my dog stays in here so
every night bro you'd be so scary oh
they stink too right huh they stink too
I didn't smell him I just live near it
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]